we are at YouTube headquarters here in
Chelsea very cool space and this is Tom
small I don't work Sarah nice to see you
how are you great
you had this VR Department is that
correct yeah I had a VR for the YouTube
spaces ok VR is virtual reality I don't
want to blow your minds with my high
tech talk but virtual reality is really
the future I think so I think it can
help us in many many ways but also I
think we should go carefully
yes that's like when you get married
yeah maybe in the future we'll get
virtual married yeah and then on
virtually fight or virtually have her
say how come you're always worried about
your show and on our children virtually
say hey that's none of your business
this show pays for everything and then
she virtually says you know what's the
name Conan anyway I never liked that
name good or anything but I am very
interested in what this means for
pornography I'm thinking of it I took
off all my clothes and I get into a cube
and then various lotions and gels are
injected into the cube sensors are put
on my body and I have incredible erotic
experiences that take me to new heights
and then I get out of the cube for five
years later we are now in the VR lab
that's right this is the latest in
technology clearly which involves I
think just green paper
we've now achieve what Weather Channel's
figured out over 40 years ago we try to
be ahead of things here we go
goggles I just hit the trigger and move
your hand through space
[Music]
how do I start with a whole freshman ok
the spin spin it around with your thumb
until you see the tool pallet with the
trash can down on the bottom back okay
now you're starting fresh would you like
to go to outer space oh man look at this
well I'm trying but only you can see
this is going to put the marijuana
industry out of business if you want to
destroy the plant no I just want to
fondle it okay again it's all gonna go
towards porn you know that but look I'm
just rubbing up against the planet now
caressing it I'll see you later
welcome to an accurate simulation of
office worker like a red velvet donut I
taste nothing we got to work on that
this is actually how I behave at the
office I want to make a Xerox copy of
the stapler backing right into the brain
watch this incredible in the future I'm
still an [ __ ] thank you look this is
an accurate simulation of gourmet chef
as this gluten-free because if it isn't
I'm gonna have virtual diarrhea
I don't think he'll take it like that I
do not gonna take it like that what's
wrong with that no you know what my
mother served me for most of my
childhood corn on the cob on a piece of
toast see if the waiter was a [ __ ] they
hit a bell
yeah the Bell will only appear if
they're gonna be happy with it oh so the
waiter doesn't like what I've made this
is the chef's kind of call the shots
look kiss and cheese how's that is that
a sandwich it's a cheese sandwich
there's a sandwich here trapped in what
are you staring at me
this could be more pornographic that's
what the future is good or sand I should
be getting it on in this kitchen see
this oil should be bring this on my body
get that oil down there you can take the
old Johnson if you know what I mean you
know I'm right that's what you have no
answer I don't want to work anymore I
want to have some fun what's next
let's take him to the gym oh my god the
hell is this guy this is your trainer
yeah this is my trainer he's lifts the
weight in I'm just looking at him I'm
just experiencing this sadness in his
eyes
this guy had a horrible childhood
what they did to you in the gulag Wow
but my apologies with ugly Joe's picture
there the yellow picture a second oh oh
my I can't I can't fight this guy you
look terrible you shouldn't be fighting
you should be back in the iron lung hi
good to see you
okay you're checking me out judging by
your shorts I don't know if we're gonna
fight or drink margaritas you have a
spot back here you should definitely
have a dermatologist look at
that was incredible hue again you
trained me and then I knocked out that
champion I know I'm the champ so I just
came here to see your face register
excitement and joy this was very
familiar to me that guys like you in the
audience and nothing I say gets a
chuckle my hair joke I had a German
girlfriend and she liked to write my
sexual performance on a scale of 1 to 10
I tried in on one night I thought I was
doing pretty well because she was
shouting nice the ideas naughty means no
so that's why that's funny I know
someone hurt you a long time ago inflate
the wall it's time to let that wall down
I can take us back to the kitchen and
there's oil there I can see you're
thinking about it
if you're interested in having sex with
me blink once
[Applause]
the YouTube game
you